and this morning's eye on money we're
going to focus on some new programs that
could boost the credit scores of
millions of americans
consumer demands for loans and credit
cards was up listen to this number
39 in april that's big compared to last
year
it's now higher than pre-pandemic levels
and banks are gearing up to help more
people borrow two initiatives
one for credit cards another for
mortgages could help expand the number
of americans
who qualify for the loans cbs news
business analyst you remember her
no because it's been over a year since
you've been sitting at our table we're
so glad to see you in person
i'm not in a little box anymore we're so
glad to see you let's talk about the
banks we keep hearing that they're
offering
credit cards to people who don't have
credit don't have a credit history
is that surprising to you well it sounds
sort of like the bad old days but that's
not what this is about this is actually
a government-backed initiative and it's
trying to get
people who've been shut out of the
credit system
get into the system and how are they
going to do that they're going to expand
the things they look at to determine
your credit worthiness so
do you pay your bills on time what's
your account balance and you know this
is really important because there are
certainly people in lower income
communities people of color
and younger people who have essentially
not been able to get credit
so i think this is a good program it's a
good step forward to get
more people in the pool what do you
think people should know before they get
open up a credit card i remember i got
my first one in college it just came to
me
yeah i was very excited i felt so grown
up yes and i got into trouble
and this do you think people should know
this is the warning story of course we
know credit can be dangerous so before
you sign to up
for anything we are talking about
understanding the rules
the fees the penalties the interest rate
and one thing that's really important
about
credit and credit history is a big
component of your credit history is
do you pay your bills on time so i
suggest that people
set up automatic payments before they
get start this process so they never
miss a payment there's never a late fee
there's no nasty surprise when we talk
about establishing a credit history
explain to people what that means well
what is really happening is a bank or a
lender is trying to say
hey is anthony a good risk should we
extend money to
him and will he pay it back the way you
establish a credit history is that you
have to actually
get credit credit yes and this is really
weird because people say well i can't
have a history because i can't have
credit again that's why these programs
don't seem like you're catching
into it it's true but why is this so
important because
credit is an important component of your
personal financial management
you're going to need to borrow money at
some point maybe for a car
maybe for a house and without a credit
history
that may actually shut you out of those
markets it may force you to pay more in
interest so
we want people to have credit we want
them to use it responsibly that's really
important
so jill for the 53 million americans or
so who are credit invisible
where could they look for resources to
learn about all those things you know
when your
cycle your bill closes it's different
from your payment date your minimum
payment versus
what's actually due there's so many
things that are just confusing i think
that one of the great developments
is seeing the consumer financial
protection bureau
really amp up their their website so the
it's i think it's consumerfinance.gov
cfpb they've got a lot of resources
there a lot of tools
but really this is on you to some extent
because
banks are going to give you this money
you've got to learn how to use it
responsibly now we're hearing that
mortgage
refinancing just got easier for some of
the low-income buyers
so what how much money are you talking
about there how important is this
this is a great program so fannie mae
and freddie mac have two different
programs those are the
government-sponsored entities
seven million people refinanced last
year but the government says one of them
and the government says 2 million
couldn't why they lost hours they lost
income they lost jobs they were
furloughed this program is going to
expand eligibility again looking at
other metrics and this should help a lot
of borrowers save
100 to 250 bucks a month so these are
homeowners who were not able to
refinance
it is still a great time to refinance
you may qualify so you really should
check that out quickly jill
wells fargo reportedly is planning to
shut down all existing personal lines of
credit
this is this is a big bank that's a lot
of people what's the impact of that well
i think the most important thing to
remember is that a line of credit is an
unsecured credit meaning that you don't
have collateral there's no house or car
behind it
for people who have these lines there's
not as many as you might think most
people do turn to credit cards and home
equity lines
if you have outstanding credit with
wells fargo you're a customer they're
going to allow you to pay that back over
time
if you don't they're shutting that line
down in 60 days you may want to shop for
i think they just want to get out of the
business it's not a big enough part of
the business and i think that you should
shop around for other alternatives
remember there are other banks community
banks are great
credit unions are great they often offer
really good rates all right jill
schlesinger thank you jill
good to see you in person